for whatever reason that's why i'm
saying when god is within the
relationship and he's able to heal
things it makes him become possibly
understanding of the woman i'm not
saying this every man there are
anomalies as we've established
one thing i will try and leave you on
this for me
women
look at a man's future
which is exactly what you're saying
we're gonna look and heal to the future
men are different men look at a woman's
past because your past is going to
embarrass me in some way shape or form
and i need to bet that
i need to ensure paternity biologically
so i'm looking at a woman's past to see
if she can be within my future whereas
you're looking at my future
to see if i'm the right man that can
guide you in the right place you need to
be i don't know i mean i'm also looking
into your into your future but also into
your past because say for example i
don't know say i've met a man who
he
could i don't know you could have had a
kid somewhere i need to know that that's
not possible okay i need to know
if i've had a kid what
what as in like if you've had a kid
somewhere and you've abandoned the kid
i'm not gonna want to be with you all
right so what about if i tell you i've
had a kid if you've had a kid and you
take care of your kid and you do what
you gotta do then cool
if you if you're if you're a man of god
you're faithful you're understanding you
provide you support you do what god has
called you to do
then what's wrong with that that's got
nothing to do with my past then
everything that after the the kid thing
is all about my future but your past as
well it plays into it all right my key
is i can ignore the past if you have if
you do the right things in the future
about the past was based on the fact
that i hadn't i hadn't told you
something
but my caveat is you may tell me
something and that is a deal breaker but
this is the thing everyone needs to look
into everyone's past because
if you have a past that's wild and you
haven't tried to sort it out it's going
to creep up in the future so like you
might be
let's say
a predator
and you're like oh no i'm good i'm good
i'm good then you get with someone then
later on this person seems like yo why
are you always looking at this kid like
what's wrong with you all right girls
exactly no no no she like you know i'm
saying like she's right when you say
look into someone's past that's why you
shouldn't wife up a girl that's been ran
through like that's that's that's
exactly she she just explained it to a t
that's why you don't do it
okay so but then if both girls have been
run through
then
then there's nothing so does that mean
that the girls that have been run
through don't deserve happiness at some
point of their lives it's not about
dessert it's not deserving what did they
earn it's like what it's it's it's like
what what do the men want and are they
what the men want so your philosophy is
basically women can't change so because
they can't change
you can't turn her home to a housewife
meaning she's not going to change her
past so because she can't change her
past meaning she's never going to be
good in the future so basically just
left her there and that's it no i'm
telling you what men want and what men
say
i'm not i'm just telling you what it is
i'm telling you this is how men view it
and men don't want to wife up hoes
and so
and i'm you know there's things you can
do to increase your market value like
you you lose weight right you like
there's things you can do to like to up
your value to a guy
and it doesn't mean it's over for every
hoe but in general it's over for a lot
of them that's why you see 50 of women
over 30 being single and childless
and it's
it just proves like the whole statement
of this is a man's world so in reality
really if we don't if we don't oblige to
what you ask or say well you better fall
in london
what the hell would the fallen line like
if you know it's a
it works both ways like if i if i can't
provide for you if i'm not being the
strong man you need me to be you're not
going to select me as a mate
you're not going to give me access to
sex like this works both ways this isn't
a one-sided argument no no i'm just
saying like
there are conversations of if she's a
hoe then
like yeah she's if she's she there's
consequences to being a hoe yeah but
it's not like she don't know that i'm
pretty sure
i'm pretty sure that if
women were told like hey this is how men
view it if you got
five to
i'll say 12 5 to 12
bodies at a certain age you are deemed
as less valuable i think less women
would be in that bracket
but we're told and especially in the
church they say you can just apologize
later and you'll still get the same
husband you would have got at 22. and
that's just not true i think
you have to work for it
it's not that you can just
like forget your partner
what do they have to do they have to go
to bible study and get back together
it's
what they're telling people a lot of
people what are they gonna do a lot of
people think is is just that oh i can
just
pray it away
and i cannot
do the work that i need to do yeah
they're so this is something that i've
learned growing up they just said oh
pray pray pray pray pray and i don't
acknowledge what i need to do for myself
because the scripture says faith without
works is dead we have to do our part as
well to heal ourselves yes god will step
in where he needs to step in but if we
don't do our part we're going to be
broken and in the church there's going
to be a broken person and a broken
person coming together because they
think oh we're in the church we're fine
we're going to be able to live it up yes
i have a past but i'm okay i'm in the
church now i can do it and they never
dealt with what was back there that's
going to always come so a whole is
always going to be a hoe even if they
are in the church no matter if they're
there faithfully every single sunday if
they do not deal with what they have
done in the past they're going to be a
hole when they marry them and they're
going to be a whole at the end of their
life this is literally what i'm trying
to say about church sorry paul it's
literally like it's for yourself it's
not for the other person once you do the
work on yourself you obey the word of
god you listen to the word of god you
take it in you understand it that's when
you can heal and that's when you will
feel the true healing well and i'm not
talking about internal though i'm not
i'm saying but your result even if you
do the internal healing and you're
better the result is men don't care in
general the men the men that the girls
want the men with options
they don't they don't care they just
want to grow without a pass so why would
they deal with a girl that's gone
through all this work of healing and did
all this stuff when they could just pick
the pretty 22 year old who has it you're
healing for yourself you're not healing
for them right you're not so if you're
healing for yourself when you get to
that man whoever that man is that man
really and truly he doesn't care about
you he cares about what you give him on
face value right and so if you're also
talking about oh well i'm healing and
blah blah blah like pearl just said he
may be like that may be a little bit too
much work i'll just go for the 23 year
old who's like just cool
do you know what i mean it's like
the 23 year old could also be a hoe and
then
she could be
she could be a a hoe but only have slept
with then that bracket before it gets to
the mount where it's deemed as forget
that
she could be a hoe and slept with more
people than you but she's younger
she's got fertility and then she's low
value no no no but no because it's
because it's it's it's not just it's
fertility too
so so they'll take a younger girl with
more bodies but if she's if she's hot
and she she's 23 20 22
she can produce i mean it's at the same
hood that you can't housewife i mean at
30 she yeah the only wife and her once
once once she gets to 30 and she decides
to do a sierra and she's bored and she
wants to twerk and she wants to do this
and then all of a sudden oh she's now
low value
how many
men
especially let's say rich men you see
that in young girls actually wife the
younger girl like not a man in his 30s
going on 40 like probably like okay they
say mr is